foreign
Congress chance stones and tear gas
inside the president they're protesting
against gave the traditional
Independence Day address after months of
instability in the Latin American
country
Dina boluarte is in power because her
predecessor Pedro Castillo was stripped
of office after his attempt to dissolve
Congress and rule by decree
but many want a new democratically
elected leader and her gone there have
been months of bitter fatal protests
I come from the punyo region and we have
more than 80 dead but this murderous
government doesn't listen Dina boluarte
has taken the presidency by force she
doesn't represent us she's killing our
sons
in her address baluati tried to strike a
conciliatory even apologetic tone
the amount of victims and injured is
something that nobody wanted it is with
deep and painful dismay that I apologize
on behalf of the state for the dead the
civilians police and soldiers us she
also plays to build infrastructure
projects and hospitals in far-flung
areas
and she asked Congress for legislative
powers for the next four months to
combat insecurity and crime analyst
Javier Farley thinks despite her
unpopularity she'll cling on for the
next three years
81 percent of people disapprove her
Administration as well as 90 percent of
people disapproved the Congress
Administration but she will probably be
given these Powers because it seems to
be that it seems to be that kind of like
a I don't know if the word complexity is
the right word but there's a kind of
like you know agreement between Congress
and the president to stay empowered in
2026 instead of calling for alienation
which is what the people who are
demonstrated in Peru are demanding and
let's say there's little money in the
treasury to carry out her proposed
projects
is little Goodwill either from the
majority of peruvians who want change
John Holman Al Jazeera